Московський патріархат програв черговий
суд Він має як написано в судовому
рішенні шляхом звільнення повернути
будівлі які власне належать
національному заповіднику але ми бачимо
що Московський патріархат залишається
більше того говориться про якихось
невстановлених осіб які там є причому це
цілюють десятки осіб які далі
перешкоджають роботі комісії
національного заповідника питання Чому в
центрі Києва а через півтора року
повномасштабного вторгнення досі ці
особи лишаються невстановленими Тому
зараз треба зробити три Прості речі
перше це застосувати закон по
з'ясовувати що це за невстановлення
особи і діяти з ними відповідно до
закону законно про воєнний стан друге -
виконати ті закони які вже є зокрема
щодо перейменування і для тих в
Московському патріархаті які хочуть
залишатися з Москвою вони просто мають
звільнити всі державні і комунальні
приміщення і третє
заборонити Московський Патріархат в
Україні